Uh, let's go next to our caller from the seven
five, four area code.
Who's calling today from seven, five, four.
And uh, where are you calling from as well?
[inaudible] my name is John and do, and I'm
constantly on county, Florida.
Hey, how are you doing John?
I'm doing good.
And my question for you is, I'm going to about
generational theory and especially about the
Strauss.
How Siri on generation and have you ever heard
about it?
Yeah.
I actually interviewed, um, was it straight?
I think it was how I interviewed.
How about it?
Um, and if I recall correctly or was it Strauss
now I don't remember if I recall correctly.
Isn't Steve Bannon like a big follower of
that?
Yeah, yeah.
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, I don't have that.
I'm sorry, what was that?
He kinds of looting and progressive in his
own way.
Yes.
You know, try to be a force for the right
wing populism.
Right?
I feel like no way.
This drug house very, um, like do you actually
look at it like some people would say this,
um, Mr given a bias.
Okay.
It takes in the post and ray, no.
Um, idea of generation, but I feel like that's
it.
It might seem unscientific like as it is now,
but it's like these, as you look into the
theory, a region lineup with a lot of stuff
that we experienced for the last 82, you know,
160 years.
Here's the thing, John.
So here's the thing in general, anytime that
you take, so you're completely right that
Strauss, how generational theory is a theory
that is not a be testable because all we can
do is see whether it applies, whether we can
apply it historically, it's almost like what's
called in, in uh, graphical science.
It's a best fit line.
It's, we're taking all of this data and we're
after the fact drawing a line that looks like
a pattern.
And so this is just like a systemic limitation
of this type of theory that's quite a qualitative
rather than quantitative and we're applying
it retroactively.
So for me, whenever I see a theory like that,
it could be an interesting theory or not an
interesting theory.
There can be elements of it that we should
sort of consider, uh, in terms of what they
would tell us about how the future is going
to go or should be handled.
But beyond that you need to make sure you're
not trying to apply these theories that are
used retroactively to find patterns after
the fact.
You don't want to over apply them to figuring
out the future when it's not actually warranted
by the type of theory that it is.
Yeah, there's just a, if that saying, um,
the best way to predict the future is to look
into the past.
Sure.
For like the Stock House very really, you
know, goes into there is the, you know, the,
the two, the two foods, Neil, Neil, Neil Howe
and William Strauss, he looked into, you know,
no, no, 500 years of American angle history
and were able to find certain patterns like,
okay, Whoa, like every eight years is a crisis
that happens by the, you know, you know, the
certain like, you know, each generational
like, you know, the awakening, the hide and
weakening the unraveling and prices in a queen
of Crisis Com.
It goes back to the highs like oh wait, no,
just a way to Penn, you know, goes like design.
Exactly.
Seeing that we'll get the get the feature,
but it's like how each generation in the archetype
notice the, the hero, the nomads is civic
in the artists.
Like each of them have archetype that catch
with the best tonight.
Some in some in some way.
Predictably we act with this predictable,
but no, he shouldn't eat, you know, event
is different.
Absolutely.
Now let me ask you this question, John, knowing
that, what specific actions could we or should
we be taking now for improving the future?
Okay, so right now, um, when you look into
the fury is this same right now we are missing
in the crisis mode of the generation of fruits
apparently when the, when the time where no,
no, great international conflict, economic
downturn, no social cohesion is in, is in
the deck, is in the um, in Kuwait, Asian,
like this, like Ooh, down.
It was like currently the crisis is like they
say it's that this is every 22 years with
each generation of most.
So currently we are in the final half of the,
of the crisis mode and we had really had the
economic meltdown can go eight.
So but what should we, what should we do on
the basis of identified that pattern?
So what we'll do is like currently it's like
we can complete the painting but we, we can
see how goes and currently what I'm saying
is we're looking right now international conflict.
Got You.
Okay.
So I understand, I understand you're saying
that that's what we're looking at.
But again, what I would start to think about
when we want to really understand what, which
of these models are useful.
What we want to know is how can we apply it
to the current situation to actually do something
to improve.
And I'm not saying that we can't, I'm just
saying it seems that you haven't yet identified
at that.
I'm trying to get, oh how things go.
I'm just looking like, oh whoa.
Like what happened between World War Two ended
the depression.
They feel, so here we similarly no to what's
going on currently in art now day and age,
I felt like, okay, currently dam, we look
into a third World War, which I'm not advocating
for brain seems so likely.
I was going on internationally.
We could have the next great depression.
Obviously a recession, a recession.
Currently how is going on?
You can tell me again, you know, financial
assistance.
Gotcha.
Okay.
So it's pattern recognition.
You're using it to recognize.
All right John, thank you.
Appreciate it.
Yes, I'm familiar with it and check out the
interview, uh, on my channel.
Um, okay.
Related to that because that is a, it is a
doozy.